انا من بيروت العميل الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري
والاستراتيجيه عميد الياس حنا هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه
تقول هناك اربعين غاره و60 هجوم صاروخي
وقع اليوم فقط كيف نفهم دلالات هذا
التكثيف والتصعيد الحاصل على الجبهات
المختلفه
جمال القصف في العمق فعلا هو مرتبط مباشره
بالهجوم الاوكراني اثنين هذه القصف على
الداخل الاوكراني هو ليس اليوم وبدا منذ
المرحله الثانيه مع الجنرال الروسي
سيروفيكي عندما استلم قياده العمليات على
المسرح الاوكراني والهدف دائما هو خفض
قدرات الجيش الاوكراني منع الهجوم والهدف
البعيد المدى هو جعل اوكرانيا بلدا غير
قابل للعيش لانه اليوم
القسم يستهدف ايضا مدن مدنيه ومدنيين في
عده اماكن من اوكرانيا ولكن كل شيء اليوم
يجب ان نضعه في اطار الهجوم الاوكراني
الكبير المنتظر تصادر البريطانيه تتحدث عن
ان هناك عدد كبير من الروس سقطوا جراء
من الطرفين ايضا
من الطرف الاوكراني ايضا ولكن الاكثر من
الطرف الروسي
وهذا منذ معركه
ما هو تقديرك لهذه الخسائر
جمال هناك اربعه محاور للهجوم حتى الان
يعني من كريمينا الى مخموت الى الوسط وحتى
الى
هذا الامر دائما اليوم هناك من يدافع
وهناك من يهاجم وعاده المستوى لكل مدافع
يجب ان يكون هناك ثلاثه مهاجمين ودائما
الخرق على جبهه كان وقت كبير للجيش الروسي
للاستعداد لها على ثلاث مستويات يعني
القوى في المقدمه حقول الالغام
الخنادق والحفر وبالتالي القوه
الاحتياط هذا الامر يستلزم يعني
خرق مهم جدا وهذا امر صعب عاده بالامور
الدفاعيه لانه الجيش الروسي يستعمل الدفاع
المرن او الفليكس من هنا بين الاخذ والرد
هذه العمليه تستلزم او تستهلك او تؤدي الى
مزيد من القتلى وتعلم الجيش الروسي
من بعد سقوط اقليم خركاب ولكن اللي هي
عمليه الياسم القصف مستمر على مقاطعه
كورسكا هل يمكن ان يستمر هذا عمليات القصف
هذه ويتسع ربما نطاقها مع الاعلان عن خطط
روسيه لاجلاء السكان من تلك المناطق
جمال كورسك وبيل جورود هي عمليه ثانويه
فعلا لخداع هي لالهاء جيش الروسي لالهاء
ونقل الارض الحرب الى الارض الروسيه او
داخل الروسي وبالتالي تثبيت قوات عسكريه
روسيه لعدم استعمالها في مكان اخر ولكن
اللعبه الكبرى جماليه دائما في هذا الخط
الذي يمتد 900 كم تقريبا هل سيحدث الخرق
اين سيكون وما هو الحجم الكبير والى اين
قد تصل القوات الاوكرانيه لا نزال اليوم
في الاسبوع الثاني من العلوم ولا اعتقد
اننا بدانا فعلا الهجوم انها عمليه
استطلاع عمليه جست نبض يعني معرفه اماكن
الضعف الروسيه وبالتالي احداث الخرق
والوصول الى بحر ازوف او قطع جسر البري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه المتحدثا من
بيروت عميد الياس شكرا لك على الافاده